[Music]
they uh
we're kind enough
so Eric now is starting with photograph
complexity for meta complexity
thanks a lot I'm very sorry for Richie
couldn't be here and you'll be even more
sorry because I'm a poor substitute but
um
I stepping in at the last minute and
what I was asked to do is sort of give a
an introductory boot camp lecture on
komogorov complexity so there's a ton of
information we won't be covering it I'm
going to just give you a few Basics that
are relevant and that some of you
probably you know think you uh already
know about komogorov complexity but
maybe uh you know you haven't looked
into this so
without raising your hands I hope people
are familiar with the fact that there
are two basic different flavors of
komogorov complexity the so-called plain
version
uh we use
C of X usually to denote that it's the
length of the shortest description such
that
you pick some Universal turing machine
and you just stick with that forever if
you feed that description into the
universal machine it gives you X and
since you've already seen
other Notions of komogorov complexity
where
you don't actually
produce X but just given description and
the number I can say what the ith bit of
X is these are actually equivalent
definitions
so
uh komogorov complexity could have been
defined either way
and so these are not the two different
varieties this is the same flavor the
other flavor is so-called prefix free
and I didn't write the definition here
because it looks exactly the same
the only difference is what qualifies as
a description so in the prefix free
version if the universal machine given
some description outputs X
that implies that for every string of Z
the universal machine on DZ
doesn't produce any output
so
there's not too much difference between
these uh
C of x
is uh
you know K of X is at most C of X plus
an additive logarithmic term so you
might ask yes this question about C of X
so the weights defined um
Okay so
here we're not saying
how do you know what the length is so
you have to pick some convention and so
if the length of X is n and I is n plus
one well you'll just reject on both of
those
or you can reject on every number
greater than n
you know pick any convention
um they're all going to give you
basically the same notion
that's
um
I'm not sure I understand the question I
mean this definition makes sense
and I'm just avoiding the issue about
how we specify the length of the
strength and
you know I'm going to sweep an even more
important details under the rug
[Music]
so yeah we've got these two Notions and
you might ask a reasonable question why
do we need two Notions
um well one reason is that certain
things or I mean this is definitely a
simpler definition
so great uh also it's got the nice
property
is that the complexity of any string X
is less than or equal to the length of X
Plus
some constant
where the constant you know depends on
what the universal machine is that
you're using
um not so nice
okay I should make this on a different
line you know you have to give some
space here
things that are not so nice
is that K of x
is less than or equal to length of X
Plus well you can't get an additive
constant there anymore you know you can
add
a logarithmic term and you can improve
that a little bit if you want to but you
can't improve it much basically you've
got to have at least log length x
um
so
if you're sticking with prefix free
complexity
um you don't have this nice property
that the complexity of X is just an
additive constant greater than the other
thing but
what's a nice property of K of X well
the complexity of the string K of X Y
is uh K of X Plus K of Y you know again
plus a constant so the amount of
information in X Y is just what's in X
Plus what's in y whereas it's not the
case for c c of X Y is not equal to C of
X plus C of Y plus order one and of
course the reason why is that if you've
got a couple of descriptions
you need a little bit of extra
information to figure out where one
description ends and one the other
begins uh even more importantly
um
is that uh
the sum over all strings acts 1 over 2
to the K of X converges
which means that you have
a way to define something that's a lot
like a probability distribution on Sigma
star
and if you do this for C it diverges
and
this property is really really useful
it's useful for you know so what can we
say
the komogorov complexity of x
scratch that
in this probability distribution the
probability of X is about 1 over 2
through the
tomagorov complexity of x
and
this is one reason why in the
computability literature you'll find a
lot more instances of people using this
K notion the prefix free notion then the
C notion question is it like
like you prove that there's no Universal
machine that has a measure that captures
yes
I'm not going to do it now but that's a
theorem
um
so
uh
this fact that common garage complexity
is related to this probability
distribution is known as the coding
theorem
and
a lot of the theorems in komogoric
complexity are kind of trivial to prove
once you you know what it is you're
trying to prove this is one of the
examples where you actually have to do
some work in order to prove it and it's
a really nice useful property and you
know it's a question
to what extent can this be done with
some sort of resource-mounted uh
komogorov complexity sometimes you can
gank that work other times not so clear
sorry
you're saying that's a theorem that's
not a definition or what is it here this
is a theorem so in other words
you can think about the following uh
following experiment you've got this
Universal machine
that uh
is just flipping coins so it's got
some random sequence
and each point it wants to uh you know
get the next bit
if it wants another bit and it just
flips a coin and so
some of the times that's going to output
something other times it won't
and
uh
when it does output something you can
ask what's the probability that it
outputs something and you get this
furthermore
any time that you try to define
something that is like a probability
distribution on Sigma star
so something that converges and more or
less satisfies the axioms of probability
Theory and is computable
it's going to have probability related
to this and so this is like the optimal
probability distribution that you can
get and so there are a number of
theorems
related to that and they all kind of are
lumped together as decoding theorem yes
so when you define the experiment where
the universal treatment with coins
for the description well
it only works in the prefix free setting
you can uh
do this same thing using the plane
complexity notion of description but
then
if
you know in this experiment if it
decides to output something X well it's
never going to continue in doing
anything else so it's going to give you
a prefix free notion of
um
of descriptions
okay so those are the main reasons why
we've got these uh
two different uh
a few different Notions of complexity
and um
one other thing I want to emphasize here
I mentioned it very briefly there's this
important property called invariance
which is that if I Define komogorov
complexity on one machine
versus using a different machine
they're going to agree up to an additive
constant and this holds also for K
complexity
and
the proof of this again is pretty
trivial just using the notion of a
universal Turing machines
but um
I want to emphasize something that uh
sort of a pet peeve of mine sometimes
you hear komogorov complexity called
program size complexity and people say
okay the input to the universal machine
is the program that describes X
not true
okay
um
the universal machine
what is a universal machine well
it takes some description of a machine
which is like the program
and it takes some data
and it simulates the machine on that
data okay now if you just
try to Define things in terms of a
machine and you want the minimum
length or size of a machine in some
sense
such that M let's say running on the
empty string gives X
you're not going to have
this property
it's not too hard to show that you can
define something like this but the um
you know the complexity of X this way
you know let's call it C tilde of x
will be less than or equal to
you know some constant times the length
of X but you're not going to be able to
get something like length x plus order
one or length x times order one just
because
of the syntax of programs uh
you know you can try to do clever things
using the recursion theorem it's not
going to work
so um
so you know that's why I use the term
description it's not a program it's the
program and the data and that together
is what uh
uh the input to the universal Machinists
I mentioned the coding theorem there's
one other
really important
theorem
that holds for uh these Notions of
commodore's complexity
which is again the the important basic
theorem that's not so trivial to prove
which is called symmetry of information
foreign
that the complexity
of
the string that gives you these two
strings separated by commas so you know
what's X you know what's y the
complexity of that is equal to the
complexity of X plus the complexity of Y
given X
plus or minus order uh
actually
order complexity of X Y
uh I'm stating it for K instead B it
also holds for C of course because
K and C agree up to an additive
logarithmic term uh and of course
this uh
is symmetric which is part of where the
uh the name comes from
foreign
yes log
thank you
pardon
it's good to hear you it's an easy proof
well yes yes
um so
and pure information Theory you know
Shannon's information Theory
theorems like this hold without the
additive logarithmic terms
well you know we can't uh quite match
that
um but it's
useful in many different settings in the
study of komogorov complexity and
again this is something that just
doesn't hold uh for certain Notions of
time-bounded komogorov complexity
and in other Notions it's wide open uh
so
long pray and Watanabe showed that for
certain Notions of time-bounded
komogorov complexity if it holds then
there are no one-way functions uh and
you can see what's going on you know if
you can think about
X and f of x
um
well given
X it's really easy to get f of x given f
of x seems to be really hard to get X if
it's a one-way function and so this
symmetric aspect just uh wouldn't
wouldn't hold and that's a theorem also
yeah
I
[Music]
so like this now
just think of of X comma y being double
all the bits of X double all the bits of
Y and have a comma symbol that's just
zero one
okay
um
so those are
a few of the basic theorems of General
komogorov complexity the other important
theorem that I guess everybody here
probably knows is that uh all of these
Notions that we've put up here are not
computable which of course is why or one
reason why there's so much interest in
having computable Notions
um what you might not know is the degree
to which
these things
are
and are not computable so
um let's focus on the random strings so
let's say R Sub C is the set of all X
such that the complexity of x
in order to be consistent with what I'm
going to do later in the talk let's say
things that are
pretty random so have complexity at
least half the length of the string
and similarly let's say R sub K is the
same thing defined in terms of K
complexity
so
so what
uh here's a theorem the halting problem
is
weekly truth table reducible
to
the random strings
no matter how we want to Define that now
I'm sure why don't we just have a show
of hands anybody have any idea what I
mean by weak truth table reduction
of course not oh great okay
so
you all know what a touring reduction is
you know you use this as an oracle you
can solve the halting problem
it's going to be a truth table reduction
it's non-adaptive which means I can
actually just ask an exponential number
of questions to
these oracles and to get enough
information that I can solve the halting
problem however
what I'm going to do is I'm going to use
this Oracle so given M and X I want to
know if M holds on input X using this
Oracle
I can compute a running time that's
astronomically huge uncomputably huge
except with the aid of this undecidable
Oracle
and then I just run M on input X if it
doesn't halt I say ah it's never going
to Halt because the running time I've
computed is big enough that if it hasn't
holded by then it's never going to hold
in other words
this weak truth table reduction
is one where the running time is
uncomputably large
okay
a neat and kind of amazing theorem
is that
for
the C notion of complexity
you actually can
put a bound
uh you know basically there is
the halting problem is time T reducible
to uh the C random strings
you might ask well what's the running
time
and the current proof
it depends on the choice of universal
turing machine that you're using to
Define
complexity
so for certain actually the best that we
know is that there exists
a
Universal machine such that the halting
problem
is in deterministic time
I think two to the 2 to the N relative
to
the komogorov random strings using
machine C you know using a universal
machine U
um
can you do better
well we don't know for the particular
type of reduction that this theorem has
done which is the so-called disjunctive
reduction basically you just write a
list of strings and say hey are any of
these random
um there you can prove
that there is no single running time
that you can use that works for every
machine
uh
so
you know an open question
is whether or not the halting problem
is in p
relative to the random strings
for some machine you know for some
Universal machine for every Universal
machine
either way we have no idea
um
so that's
I don't know of any application to
compressive complexity Theory to be able
to answer that but it's it's just a
weird open question that yeah
um
I don't know that that has been
looked at okay
what has been looked at is what about
if you try to do this with
prefix free complexity
and there
you know there exists
a u such that the halting problem
is
uh you know is in let's say
doubly exponential time
two to the 2 to the N relative to the K
random strings and there exists another
machine
such that
is not uh
you know for every time bound t for
every computable time Bounty it's not in
deterministic time
T relative to the coma Grove random
strings and so this is an instance
let me back up what makes komogorov
complexity interesting is in part this
invariance theorem that says it doesn't
make any difference which Universal
machine you use
except sometimes it does
and this is an example where yeah
sometimes it does
yeah you know we're when I'm talking
about
a
well the definition of a truth table
reduction in the computability setting
is basically that there is a turing
reduction
in some computable time bound you know
it's always going to halt
for every Oracle that you use which is
the same thing as it's going to Halt if
you have the empty Oracle which means
it's a computable timeout
yeah
anyone reductions can you rule out more
so for many one reductions
now first of all what is the set of all
languages a such that a is m reducible
to the halting problem
and let's say ac0 or even nc0 reducible
to the halting problem
this is something you all know whether
you know you know it or not
is this the computably innumerable steps
I mean it's the halting problem is
complete
it's complete with reductions you know
or you've got your hand tied behind your
back whatever
what is the set of things
that are polynomial time reducible to
let's say the uh
three random strings or the K random
strings
rep reductions what can you reduce to
this undecidable set
with an M reduction
nothing outside of P
okay M reductions are useless
when you're reducing to the common Grove
random strings but pardon computable
sets
thank you
intersect the decidable sets
is p you know with the modulo the usual
things well there's empty set and sigma
star you can't do but
okay
so
uh yeah you for decidable sets which are
the ones we care about
M reductions are useless to
talk about the C random strings
um
and this is sort of a you know what do
we think
let's look at some decidable Notions of
komogorov complexity uh you know a such
that a is polytime M reducible to let's
say the random strings using uh
KT definition of komogorov complexity
that was discussed yesterday
you know a lot of people would
conjecture maybe this is all of NP okay
so you seem to get more with a weaker
Oracle
than with a more powerful Oracle this is
not weird
this is actually
what you expect with an M reduction
because
M reductions
on the no instances
after produce complex strings
or I can see the way I did it here and
on the yes instances they have to
produce complex strings
you just can't do that with a computable
reduction
so
even you know if you if you want to
compare these two sets uh the things
that are in reducible to the
random strings using that notion versus
uh the things that are reducible
to the 11 random strings
uh
you actually expect
actually you expect that these are going
to be incomparable
um
but
it should not be surprising that there
are going to be things reducible to this
easier Oracle which is in NP
that are not going to be reducible with
this type of reduction to uh the more
powerful Oracle uh which is complete for
exponential time
so and it's again just due to the
difficulty in formulating meaningful
queries
um
so if you look at more powerful Notions
of reducibility
then this goes away
to some extent
um
so
so
I missed the last like why is it yes
yes
because you're getting you're giving it
right so the um
so let's do the theorem theorem
foreign
be decidable
and a
polytime m-reducible to the C random
strings
then a is in P proof
why is this true
um
that uh
X be equal to
the Set uh
of all
let
got this reduction
that F be the function that reduces
a to
R Sub C
um
let
uh
X be equal to the set
f of x such that X is in a
this is a subset of R Sub C
right because that's what reductions do
uh this is finite
because if you've got infinitely many
things
you know it's finite let's just write it
that way
less than infinity if you've got
infinitely many strings in there okay
then you can say Okay given n give me
the first
string
and X of length
greater than I don't know 2 to the 2 to
the n
you can find that and you've got a
really short description of it it can't
be random there's the there's the
contradiction
Okay so
for M reductions
M reductions have a hard time with
that's defined in terms of komogorov
complexity
um
there was a question that Han Lin asked
yesterday which I made a note of and it
was basically
uh Valentine proved the theorem or
mentioned the theorem nc1
is contained in the class of things that
are AC zero reducible to
mcsp and this was a non-uniform
reduction
and uh Hanlan asked a question well what
about uniform probabilistic reductions
um actually I don't think we know
anything much more about this
but
we really know
pretty precisely
what is
the center of all a such that a is let's
say
randomly reducible
to
unless they randomly AC zero reducible
I'll write r a c 0 m reducible to m k
c p
uh
do I need to remind people what mktp is
you've
been hearing over and over and over
again about mcsp
and this is where the
complexity measure is circuit size and
if we just replace circuit size with
this time-bounded version of komogorov
complexity you get mktp
and um
I should explain what a actually I'm
going to do this make this correct I'll
make it a BP
AC zero reducibility
um
this is a reduction
where
uh
we're even going to Define this for
promise problems so you've got yes
instances and no instances
and here's
mktp so we've got uh
uh
the yes instances for mktp
and the no instances
and
a bpac0 reduction
is something that takes input X and a
bunch of random bits
and produces outputs y
such that if x is a yes instance we're
almost certainly going to end up with a
yes instance and if x is in no instance
we're almost certainly going to end up
with a no instance
so it's an M reduction
but probabilistic and we've probably
most of the people here have seen
probabilistic reductions one size one
one way or another
so
this class
uh the class of things that are
reducible to
mktp
contains
a complexity class that nobody here
almost has ever heard of
this
is contains the complexity class
n i s z k l
people here have heard of interactive
proofs right I don't need to explain
interactive proofs probably most people
here know about zero knowledge
and
well there's computational zero
knowledge there's also statistical zero
knowledge
and
statistical zero knowledge is what you
get
um
where you've got a prover or a verifier
interacting with a prover
B
in the usual way of interactive proofs
where for the yes instances of the
problem there is also a simulator
that can produce a distribution that
looks
uh it doesn't even look it actually is
very close to the Distribution on
conversations between the actual
verifier and the prover
and
with the non-interactive version of this
the prover and the verifier
can each
see
the input X
and they each see some random bits
and the convert the communication
is just that the
prover talks to the verifier there's no
further interaction
and this is something that
that
uh
cryptographers were really interested in
because it gives them oh you know you
can do
have some interesting protocols for
interesting problems uh in that way and
the nice theorem
is that
statistical zero knowledge
and NIS
z k
have essentially the same complexity if
you've got anything you can do with an
ordinary statistical zero knowledge
uh protocol there's something in
non-interactive zero knowledge
that is you can reduce to it you can
reduce it too so there's something hard
here if and only if there's something
hard there
and this is closed under complement we
don't
know if this one is and so here's Co
music
and I actually wrote this wrong this is
co music L which is uh reducible to
M KTP using these ac0 reductions what's
the L stand for
well for various reasons different
people introduced log space versions of
this where the verifier and the
simulator
are log space computable
a lot of the problems that people are
interested in that are in SDK are in SDK
with these log space computable
verifiers
and um
it turns out that there are some other
stuff you can do in the log space
setting and one of those things is that
you can get mktp hard under these
probabilistic ac0 or even nc0 reductions
uh
and
one reason that I'm introducing this now
or mentioning this now
is
that you get even a nicer
connection
uh
if you look at
the non-computable version of commodore
of complexity namely
uh
foreign
you know be a promise problem
and let's Let It Be decidable
so the yes instances are decidable the
no instances are decidable
then a is in
n-i-s-z-k
if and only if
a is BPP
honest M reducible honest just means you
don't ask really short questions
to
the komogorov random strings I'm putting
a tilde over there
what's that
uh
X is in the yes instances for r k tilde
if
uh the K complexity of X is greater than
or equal to the length of X over two
and it's a no instance
if and only if
K of X is less than or equal to
length of X over 2 minus an error term
where the error term
can really be almost anything
algorithmic you know super logarithmic
to
the end of the little low of one
so
so
what
this is not computable we've established
that
actually for 20 years yeah
if and only if
so for 20 years
I've been
trying to get my hands on what is
efficiently reducible
to the Commodore of random strings or to
the problem of computing komogorov
complexity and I made a bunch of really
bad conjectures many of which were
disproved by shuichi hirohara
but these conjectures were of the form
you know maybe we get a really nice
familiar complexity class
by looking at things that are reducible
to the komogorov random strings
and
it turns out
that if you use
the right notion of reducibility
and
we allow
a lot of don't care conditions so we're
just asking about approximating the
komogorov complexity
and if you're generous in your notion
about what's a nice complexity class
well it it works you know that it
actually happens
and the thing that's sort of shocking
about this
is that
you know it shouldn't be right I mean
this is something that
people who are interested in building
smart card machines uh you know it's
ways that you could prove your identity
identity quickly without revealing
information
uh
a practical notion you know it turns out
to be exactly characterized
in terms of
reductions to this non-computable notion
and this is another example where
you know if you look at um
the KT random strings or something like
mktp
that should be you know it's decidable
it's sitting inside NP
um
it's not expected to be reducible
to this undecidable thing because that
would put
this thing that's hard for
cognizik
inside music
and
in fact it even gets weirder than that
remember I introduced this log space
version
um
you can also say a is in nizik
l
if and only if a
is
random
log space honest and reducible to R till
Decay or a is
uh random NC zero honest and reducible
to R till decay
or anything in between or BPP versions
also a uh VP L honest and reducible to R
tilde K basically any kind of
not very powerful probabilistic
reduction
gives you
this log space class
um
and
I've got 10 minutes left so
let me just mention
one other thing that you get out of this
so but I mentioned it started to mention
this is another example where
the thing is that you can reduce to a
more complex set
maybe is a smaller class in the things
you can reduce to a less complex set
like mktp because if
if
uh
if that weren't the case then mktp would
actually be in here and then a bunch of
really weird stuff happens so
if m k t p is in
n i s z k l
then
let's look at the complete language
or
music l
complete language for nizik l
has my initials
entropy approximation is
the stat of all
circuit C
uh well the yes instances the set of all
circuit C and number K such that the
entropy of the distribution represented
by C
is greater than let's say K plus 1 and
the no instances
to the set of all pairs c k such that
the entropy of a distribution C is less
than K minus one so you know there were
your input is a circuit
it takes a bunch of random bits as input
and produces some string y as output
so it imposes a distribution on the Y's
and the question is what can you say
about the entropy of that distribution
yeah
right so for nizik l
uh this
is an nc0 circuit
or it could be a branching program
either way you get something that's
complete for uh music l
um
now
unconditionally we know
that
this problem
the complement of it is reducible to
mktp Via
a probabilistic reduction but also
Co music
Al L is projection
M reducible to m k t p
foreign
is a reduction
here's an nc0 circuit which just means
that every output bit depends on a
constant number of input bits at most a
projection is where that constant is one
so every output bit
basically there are no Gates they're
just not Gates
there are wires that feed
inputs to outputs so in other words
these projection reductions
aren't really doing much of computation
at all they're just
plugging the input into a into a
template and you know sat is complete
under projections these problems are
complete just about any complexity class
you're interested in
the complete problems that you're
familiar with are going to be complete
under projections
um
and so in some sense it's not too
shocking that
you can show that this thing is that we
know is complete under some other notion
of reduction is complete under
projections
um
except that
we don't know and what else do we know
uh
this thing also projection
reduces to
the komogorov
approximation problems
uh for random strings
um
so
these are non-uniform and in fact that's
crucial
um
well I mean actually for this result
it's not inconceivable
that they could be uniforms somehow
but
if
mktp is in this class
which contains a fairly good sized chunk
of pea actually the determinant is in
here if mktp is in that class
then
there exists
a projection
f
such that
if
KT of x
is small
that implies that the
komogorov complexity of f of x
is big
so you know it takes the all zero
strings and outputs something with high
comogorous complexity that can only
happen with a non-uniform projection but
it could happen but also if you take
anything that's got high complexity
then
it's mapping it to something with
significantly
lower complexity
minus you know something big to the
let's say square root log in something
like that
so in other words you take something
that's got almost no information at all
and you feed it into this little device
and you get out a bunch of information
but if you feed a bunch of information
into it
you get out not much you know it's like
you pour water in and you get milk and
you pour milk in and you get water
and
you know we understand computation so
little
that
if it weren't just a projection doing
that
it would be hard to say well why not
but projections aren't really doing much
um
and also the fact that we're the thing
we're reducing it to
is basically an information theoretic
object there's things that either have a
lot of information or not very much
information
um
and also you know with this is the fact
that in order to get this type of result
we're using some non-relativizing proof
techniques I mean it's it's reasonably
plausible
that one can just show that this can't
happen
and if you can do that
well then you've separated NP which
contains mktp
from you know non-deterministic log
space or
amounts of things you know so this
probably won't work
almost you know nothing else has worked
but
it's worth
um
at least trying to figure out
if it might work
and so
um you know if people ask what's a goal
for the semester you know for me a goal
for the semester is separate MP from log
space
you know show that this will will work
I'd be happy with that yeah
so um
I didn't cover everything I thought I
might cover but uh I've used up my time
and uh
I yield the floor
thank you
yes so you were saying there exists a
projection at and this is the same
projection for both of us yeah actually
the argument
that
um shows that this works
uses the fact
that
what's the I can just show you what the
projection looks like
um
here we've got this nc0 circuit I want
to know what its entropy is right
so I just take a bunch of copies of it
take a bunch of copies of it and feed
different
random strings into it and get a bunch
of samples and I just concatenate them
and in fact we can say that the KT
complexity of this string
is gives you a pretty good estimate of
the entropy
of these distributions
and
uh so asking what's the KT complexity of
this allows you to say it's got high
entropy or low entropy
and one side of that
is basically just a counting argument
using the fact that most strings have
high KT complexity well they've also got
high K complexity so this projection
Maps
low entropy distributions to things with
low KT complexity
hi
entropy distribution things with high K
complexity and it's probabilistic but
you just hardwire in a choice of the
random bits
and
uh
you know I forgot to mention that you
can build this
uh you know EA is complete under
projections for
uh you know for these the nc0 circuits
you can build them from input X via a
projection because you know for the
completeness for this problem and so
each output bit here depends on a
constant number of random bits
and only one bit of input
X so when you hardwire in the random
choices
um
a lot of this simplifies to just
constants
but everything else just depends on a
single bit and that's your non-uniform
projection
um
so yeah
it's a it's a pretty simple Construction
yes there's a question here so let's try
to understand everything so this might
be a really bad question but if it
weren't non-uniform
then it would be sort of easy to
disprove that's right because if you've
got a computable function
you feed low complexity in you get low
complexity out so the problem is the
fact that we've hard coded those bits
that's the issue so yep
foreign
way that we build this
and so you know we start off with a fair
amount of information uh and we
well I don't know
the Decay and the consequences
[Music]
then like if you assume it's MP before
you make the projection uniform
I don't know how to do that no because
then you can at least verify the
reactions
but it would be a different kind of
statement
foreign